hello and welcome to math simplified
i'm dr umar malik and in today's video
we'll be taking a look at a few natural
remedies for hypothyroidism
and if you haven't watched our previous
video on hypothyroidism
i suggest you to click the banner above
and watch that first
to get a better idea about the signs and
symptoms of hypothyroidism
but in case you're a bit lazy here are a
few things you should know
the thyroid gland is a small organ
that's located in front of the neck
wrapped around the windpipe also known
as trachea
and its main job is to produce thyroid
hormones that mainly control our body's
metabolism
now hypothyroidism occurs when the gland
fails to produce
enough thyroid hormone this leads to
symptoms such as tiredness
fatigue feeling gold hair loss dry skin
depression memory and concentration
problems
constipation and menstrual abnormalities
the treatment of hypothyroidism is very
simple daily intake of levothyroxine
tablets
millions of people worldwide are taking
levothyroxine on a daily basis and going
on with their lives without any problem
or inconvenience
that remains the standard worldwide
however there are certain things we can
do
to overall boost our thyroid health that
will not only help your body on a longer
run
but also decreases your dependence on
medications
with that in mind let's look at a few
natural supplements that will help to
manage your hypothyroidism
number one selenium
according to the national institute of
health nih
selenium is a trace element that plays a
part in thyroid hormone metabolism
hashimoto's thyroiditis is a disease in
which your body's own immune system
attacks the thyroid
which leads to a decreased thyroid
hormone production
this disease often reduces the body's
selenium supply
supplementing this trace element has
shown to help balance thyroxine or t4
levels in some people
selenium also has some other very
important functions
it acts as a powerful antioxidant it may
reduce your risk of certain cancers
it can also protect against heart
disease it helps prevent mental decline
it boosts your immune system it can also
help to reduce asthma symptoms
many foods contain selenium including
tuna
turkey brazil nuts and grass-fed beef
it's important to talk with your doctor
about how much selenium may be right for
you
since every person is different since it
may be toxic in larger
unrequired amounts number two sugar-free
diet
sugar and processed foods can lead to
increased inflammation in the body
inflammation can slow down the
conversion of t4 to dry hydrothyroidine
or t3
another thyroid hormone this can make
your symptoms of thyroid disease worsen
also sugar only boosts your energy
levels in the short term
and eliminating it from your diet may
help regulate your energy levels also
additionally removing sugar from your
diet may help your stress levels and
skin
it's not easy to adopt a sugar-free diet
but it will stabilize and ultimately
benefit your thyroid health
number three vitamin b taking certain
vitamin supplements can have an effect
on your thyroid health
low thyroid hormone can affect the
body's vitamin b12 levels
taking a vitamin b12 supplement may help
to repair
some of the damage your hypothyroidism
has done to your body
vitamin b12 can also help with the
tiredness that is caused by the thyroid
disease
in addition scientifically proven
benefits of vitamin b12 supplementation
include increased red blood cell
formation and prevention of anemia
supporting bone health and prevention of
osteoporosis
it reduces a risk of serious vision
problems such as macular degeneration
it improves mood and decreases symptoms
of depression
it prevents loss of neurons improves
heart health
and supports healthy hair skin and nails
you can add more b
vitamins to your diet with the following
foods peas
and beans asparagus sesame seeds
tuna cheese milk and eggs
vitamin b12 is generally safe for most
healthy individuals at recommended
levels
talk with your doctor about how much
vitamin b12 may be right for you
number four probiotics the nih study the
link between hypothyroidism and small
intestine problems
it was found that altered
gastrointestinal motility
commonly seen with hypothyroidism can
cause bacterial overgrowth
and ultimately lead to chronic gi
symptoms such as diarrhea
probiotic supplements contain helpful
bacteria that can help to keep your
stomach and intestines healthy
natural fermented foods and drinks which
contain probiotics include caffeine
kombucha some cheeses and yogurt
however the food and drug administration
hasn't approved the use of probiotics
for the prevention or treatment of any
condition
talk with your doctor to see if these
supplements are right for you
number five iodine iodine is an
essential mineral that's needed to make
thyroid hormones
thus people with iodine deficiency might
be at risk of hypothyroidism
iodine deficiency is very common and
affects nearly one third of the world's
population
however it's less common in people from
developed countries like the united
states
where iodized salt and iodine-rich
seafood is widely available
if you have an iodine deficiency
consider adding iodized table salt to
your meals
or eating more iodine-rich foods like
seaweed
fish dairy and eggs however it is
important to know
that iodine supplements are unnecessary
as you can get plenty of iodine from
your diet only
some studies have also shown that
getting too much of this mineral can
damage the thyroid gland number six
gytrogens
goitrogens are compounds that may
interfere with the normal function
of the thyroid gland they get their name
from the term goiter
which is an enlarged thyroid gland that
may occur with hypothyroidism
surprisingly many common foods contain
goitrogens
including soy foods like tofu tempeh
edamame certain vegetables like cabbage
broccoli
kale cauliflower and spinach fruits and
starchy plants
like sweet potatoes cassavas peaches and
strawberries
nuts and seeds including millets pine
nuts
and peanuts in theory people with
hypothyroidism should avoid quite
regions
however this only seems to an issue for
people who have an iodine deficiency
or they eat large amounts of gytrogens
scientists agree that moderate
consumption of these
as a part of a wholesome diet is
recommended for everyone
including those with hypothyroidism
unless advice otherwise
so friends these were a few natural
supplements for managing hypothyroidism
easily
to know more about other thyroid related
problems and how to manage them
stay tuned on our channel for our
upcoming videos if you like this video
don't forget to share it with your
friends and family
you might just help someone who is
confused about their symptoms
subscribe to our channel for more such
content we at med simplified are
committed to bringing you the latest
content
if you like what we do and would like to
support us consider becoming a member of
our youtube channel
or support us on patreon links are in
the description below
thank you and have an amazing day